de la musique avec un nouvel album de
véronique sanson en forme d'hommage à
michel berger une dédicace où les textes
et musique écrite par michel berger sont
souvent très peu connu sept ans après la
disparition michel berger véronique
sanson intitule son album d'un papillon
à une étoile
présentation olivier dénoue avec raymond
schappler d'un papillon et une étoile le
titre d'un album la romance de deux
artistes qui ont partagé leurs émotions
leur passion à travers leurs chansons
il est logique des deux fois
je veux
fondée
il y aura en 1967 véronique sanson
rencontre michel berger tous les deux
sont jeunes inconnus pianiste auteur et
compositeur
c
la nounou
l'accord
aujourd'hui véronique sanson donne vie
aux mélodies ciselées par michel berger
tous ces mots que lui écrivait en
pensant à elle
je voudrais connaître ma vie
il pourra prendre
devenir non
on a mûri mais pour me comprendre
ils se sont compris et puis un jour l'un
des deux s'en est allé sans oublier
d'offrir la plus romantique des minutes
de silence
ce
des corps tellement
m
ceux ci vont